[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم السيئه
بعاصف الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من القدس ومظاهرات
مناهضه لمشروع قانون التغييرات القضائيه
الذي تقدمت به حكومه بنيامين نتانياهو
وهذه الصور من روما حيث عقد مؤتمر لمناقشه
الهجره عبر المتوسط بحضور قاده من المنطقه
والاتحاد الاوروبي والمؤسسات الماليه
والدوليه ومن روما الى مدريد حيث يتناوب
اليمين والاشتراكيون احتلال المركز الاول
مع ظهور نتائج فرز اكثر من 50% من الاصوات
في الانتخابات الاسبانيه المبكره
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
توتر وترقب في اسرائيل عشيه تصويت حاسما
في الكنيست عشرات الالاف يحتشدون في شوارع
القدس ضد مشروع قانون يحد من سلطات القضاه
نتنياهو يتحدى سنواصل جهودنا لاستكمال
التشريع وتحذيرات متزايده يطلقها قاده
الجيش من التداعيات على وجود اسرائيل
سجال عنوانه هجوم اوكرانيا المضاد بوتين
يقول ان الهجوم فاشل رئيس بيلاروسيا يقول
انه لا يوجد هجوم مضاد
يقول ان اوكرانيا استعادت نصف الاراضي
التي سيطرت عليها روسيا وفي الميدان قتلى
واضرار جسيمه في هجوم روسي على اوديسا
جنوبيه اوكرانيا
في اليوم المائه من القتال في السودان
الجيش السوداني يقصف اهدافا لدعم السريع
في الخرطوم واشتباكات في ام درمان وقوات
من الدعم السريع تدخل لاول مره مدينه ام
روايه جنوب ولايه شمال كردفان وتشتبك مع
المواطنين ما ادى الى سقوط قتلى وجرحى
ووسط توتر مع كينيا عضو مجلس السياده
بالسودان ياسر العطا يخاطب الرئيس الكلي
ويقول ان عليه المواجهه
في ختام مؤتمر روما بمشاركه دول مطله على
البحر المتوسط واخرى من الشرق الاوسط
وافريقيا اتفاق على اتخاذ اجراءات للحد من
الهجره غير النظاميه وتضييق الخناق على
تهريب البشر
ورئيسه وزراء ايطاليا تعلن تنظيم مؤتمر
للمانحين قريبا في اعقاب مؤتمر الهجره
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا معكم المشهد الامنيه
والسياسيه والانساني في السودان مع مرور
مئه يوم على اندلاع القتال بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي في رايكم الى اين يتجه مسار
الاحداث في السودان بعد مرور 100 يوم على
القتال بين الجيش والدعم السريع جاءت
الاجابات على النحو التالي نحو 57% رجحوا
استمرار القتال بين الجيش والدعم السريع
بينما توقع نحو 20% ان يتمكن احد طرفي
الصراع من حسم المواجهه في حين صوت نحو
23% بالقول ان هناك امكانيه لابرام لتسويه
تفاوضيه لتثبيت وقت لاطلاق النار
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجد ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
بعد اغلاق مراكز الاقتراع في اسبانيا فرز
اكثر من 50% من الاصوات يظهر سجالا بين
اليمين والاشتراكيين
[موسيقى]
حلقات اخطر ازمه سياسيه داخليه في اسرائيل
منذ عقود تتواصل وتتشابك في مشهد قد يصل
ذروته غدا الاثنين موعد التصويت النهائي
على بند اساسيا في خطه نتنياهو المثيره
للجدل والراميه الى الحد من قدره المحكمه
العليا على ابطال قرارات من الحكومه
والوزراء نواصل المساعي لاستكمال التشريع
هي رساله نتنياهو من المستشفى بعد تركيب
جهاز تنظيم ضربات القلب اما رساله الشارع
فكانت مدويه رافعين الاعلام وقارعين
الطبول احتشد عشرات الالاف في القدس رغم
شمس الصيف الحارقه رفضا للتغييرات
القضائيه
نقاش طويل وشاق بانتظار اعضاء الكنيسه
المئه والعشرين سيمتد 26 ساعه يصوتون في
نهايته على تعديل يحيد المحكمه العليا
ويمنع قضاتها من الغاء قرارات الحكومه
واذرعها التنفيذيه والجدل بين مؤيد ومعارض
للتعديل على اشده نحن
بسيط وهدفه اعاده الفصل بين السلطات
واعاده الديمقراطيه لاسرائيل
قام انقاص الخليله
حتى لو مرروا التعديل هم يعلمون انهم
فشلوا حكومه اسرائيل تشن حرب استنزاف ضد
مواطنيها لكنها لم تستطع استنزافهم
في الخارج شكل الزحف البشري الى مباني
الحكومه في القدس الغربيه ذروه احتجاجات
شعبيه متواصله منذ مطلع العام ومع انضمام
قطاعات مختلفه من شرائح المجتمع لا يخفي
هؤلاء ان اسرائيل تسير نحو الهاويه ونحو
اتساع الشرق المجتمعي
نحن العائلات الثكله فقدنا اعزائنا في
حروب اسرائيل اولئك خرجوا للقتال من اجل
ان تكون اسرائيل دوله يهوديه وديمقراطيه
الغاء الديمقراطيه هو نكثم بالاتفاق ليس
مع الاحياء فقط بل مع الاموات ايضا
وفي المقابل يزداد عدد الجنود والضباط
الرافدين للخدمه وتزداد المخاوف لدى
المؤسسه العسكريه من فقدان الجاهزيه
القتاليه في غضون ايام وتنقسم الاراء بشان
الجدوى من اقحام الجيش في هذا الجدل
السياسي
بالنسبه للرافدين هم محقون بسبب والهدف
لكن ليس بالتوقيت فنحن اليوم نتحدث بلغه
الصراع بين الاخوه وليس بين الاعداء وننسى
ان مصطلح الحرب الاهليه يعني خراب دوله
اسرائيل
من الكواليس تجري محاولات اللحظه الاخيره
للتوصل الى تسويه قبل موعد التصويت
وتعيش اسرائيل ايام الناصريه كما يصفها
البعض ذلك ان الصراع هو على شكل الدوله
بين من يريدها ديمقراطيه متنوره ومن يسعى
الى جعلها دينيه اصوليه
وتعتبرها المعارضه انقلابا على نظام الحكم
وايا كان الامر فان مواقف محايده ترى فيها
خطه محكمه وضعها بنيامين نتنياهو لانقاذ
نفسه من ملفات الفساد التي تلاحقه
والاستبداد بالسلطه لياسك راما الجزيره
القدس غربيه
في هذه الاثناء انهى الرئيس الاسرائيلي
اجتماعا مع رئيس الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو
ومن المقرر ان يبحث لاحقا مع زعيم
المعارضه تسويه بشان التغييرات القضائيه
وكان نتنياهو قال في تصريح من داخل
المستشفى الذي يعالج فيه انه يعمل على
تمرير التعديلات بشكل توافقي
كما ترون صحتي ممتازه نحن نواصل الجهود
لاستكمال التشريعات وايضا نواصل الجهود
ليتم ذلك بالوفاق لكن وفي جميع الاحوال
اريد ان تعلموا انني غدا صباحا الى زملائي
في الكنيست
في هذه الاثناء رفض حزب الليكود مقترح
التسويه الذي تقدم به اتحاد نقابات العمال
الهيستدروت لانهاء الازمه وكان الاتحاد قد
قال ان عدم قبول التسويه المقترحه يعني
اجتماعهم مجددا لاتخاذ قرارات بشان خطواته
المستقبليه حيث يرجح ان يعلن اتحاد
النقابات اضرابا عاما يشل اسرائيل بالكامل
من تل ابيب ينضم الينا دانشفتان رئيس مركز
دراسات الامن القومي بجامعه حيفا سيدان
الى اين تتجه الازمه باعتقادك
اعتقد ان الساعات القليله المقبله سوف
تحسم الموضوع الرئيس يشارك بقوه التوصل
الى التسجيع للاسف ان الطرفين كان
متمسكين بموقفهما حتى اللحظات الاخيره ما
سمعناه في لحظات الاخيره هو ان المعارضه
تزداد ليونه والامر
منوطنياهو هل هو مستعد للتعامل مع
الراديكاليين في حكومته للاسف المعارضه
ذهبت بعيدا
بالنظر الى ان الكثيرين من الجيش والقوات
الجويه قالوا انهم ليسوا مستعدين للعمل
اذا تم تمرير هذا القانون هذا خطا كبير من
قبلهم والسؤال الان هل يمكن التوصل فعلا
الى
تسويه او هل يمكن تقديم تنازلات للتواصل
للتسويه موافق عليها من الطرفين ليس هناك
فرق كبير بالنسبه الى محتوى القضيه في
معظم القضايا يمكنهم التوصل الى توافق
ومخطط الحكومه الاكبر اصلا قد اجهد الى
مساله حكمه من الطرفين حتى يتمكن من تلافي
وضع صعب جدا
الان لا يوجد لا يبدو ان هناك بوادر توافق
وفي هذه الاجواء يقول نتنياهو انه ذاهب
غدا الى الكنيست لتمرير هذه التشريعات ان
حصل ذلك ما السيناريو اليوم الثلاثاء
المشكله لها علاقه بالتوافق في المجتمع
ولكن السؤال هو هل يمكن تخطيها سوف
نتخطاها ربما خلال اسابيع ربما خلال اشهر
ولكننا سوف نتخطاها لان ما نراه الان في
اسرائيل هو نزاع او صراع ديمقراطيه يتم
استخدام الوسائل الديمقراطيه ومره اخرى لا
يمكن ان يكون لدينا ديكتاتوريه اذا كان
الجيش والشرطه
والهيئات الاستخباريه والجميع يقف ضد هذا
الديكتاتوريه من يتحدث عن ديكتاتوريه في
اسرائيل لم يفهموا الوضع فعلا
وهذا يشمل الكثير من الاسرائيليين من جهه
اخرى موضوع سيدان ابعد من موضوع
الديمقراطيه والديكتاتوريه هناك تصريح
لرئيس اركان الجيش يحذر فيه من انعكاسات
ما يجري على وحده الجيش وعلى بقاء الدوله
من اساسها
صحيح اذا استمر الوضع سوف يكون له تابعات
خطيره ولكن هذا انذار سوف لن ينفذ لانه
اذا تعرضت اسرائيل لاي هجوم غدا الجميع
سوف يهرع الى الجيش لكي يخدم بلاده اذا
استمرت الاوضاع بدون
توافق الجيش لن يكون بنفس المستوى لكن هذا
سوف لن يحصل لان الاسرائيليين يدركون انه
بدون جيش قوي سوف لن تستمر اسرائيل ما قال
هو قائد الاركان امر جيد اسرائيل موجوده
لانها قويه واعضاء اسرائيل يعرفون ذلك انا
لا اعتقد ان هناك اي خطر في المستقبل
القريب لان الاسرائيليين سوف يعودون الى
موقف اكثر مسؤوليه من تل ابيب دان شفتان
رئيس مركز دراسات الامن القومي بجامعه
حيفا
ومعنا من واشنطن دانيال استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه جونز
سيدانيا باي عين تراقب الاداره الامريكيه
اتساع هذا الشرخ في اسرائيل مع العلم ان
الرئيس الامريكي كان صريحا في السابق
واعلن انه لا يدعم هذه التعديلات التي
تنوي الحكومه تمريرها
اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده لا تزال تعتبر
ان
هذه التغييرات سوف لن تمر ولكن الولايات
المتحده
ليس لديها تاثير قوي على هذا الوضع
لان تاثيراتها تاتي من التعاون الدفاعي
الذي هي اصلا ترغب في الاستمرار به اذا
اعتقد ان نتنياهو لا يولي انتباها كبيرا
للولايات المتحده ما دلالات هذا اللقاء
الذي يجمع الرئيس الاسرائيلي هيرتسوك معنى
تنياهو في المستشفى لاسيما انه يجري
مباشره بعد عوده هيرسك من زيارته الى
الولايات المتحده
الرئيس هو رمز الدوله وسوف يحاول ان يمنع
حصول كل ما يهدد الدوله الاسرائيليه
وطبعا هذا الانقسام بين المعارضه والحكومه
اذا استمر لفتره طويله من شانها ان يهدد
امن دوله اسرائيل كما افاد
الزميل الضيف السابق وبالتالي من الطبيعي
ان يقوم الرئيس
بمحاولات للتوسط التواصل الى حال ولكنني
لا ارى اي مؤشر الى ان نتنياهو مستعد
للتراجع
ان جهوده من اجل تعزيز سيطره الحكومه على
سلك القضائي ياتي ردا لما يرهه هو تهديدا
وجوديا له شخصيا وهو مصمم على الاستمرار
والصمود في حال استمر وصمد
واستطاع ان يمرر هذه التشريعات في الكنيست
كما يعد من دون توافق من دون توافق مع
المعارضه بطبيعه الحال كيف يمكن ان تتعامل
الولايات المتحده مع كل التداعيات
المحتمله لذلك وما يجري التحذير منه على
اكثر من مستوى في داخل اسرائيل
الامر مرتبط بما يحصل في اسرائيل في ذلك
الحين كما قلت الولايات المتحده ليس لديها
تاثير كبير هنا فتعاونها مع اسرائيل هو في
القضايا الدفاعيه وكذلك الاقتصاديه وهي
شيء تريد الولايات المتحده الاستمرار به
لا تسعى
الى تاثير على سلوكيات اسرائيل من خلال
توقف عن التعاون
الامر سوف يعتمد كثيرا على ما يحصل بعد
ذلك اذا كان هناك اي قمع للمظاهرات
وهذا اعتقد سيستمر بعد تمرير التشريع فهذا
سوف يؤدي الى ردود فعل جديه في الولايات
المتحده
معظم الامريكيين لاسيما اليهود منهم لا
يدعمون حكومه نتانياهو
هذه التغييرات التشريعيه
اشكرك من واشنطن استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
في جامعه
اذا لا تزالوا اعداد جنود الاحتياط
الرافدين للبقاء ضمن الخدمه الطوعيه على
خلفيه التغييرات القضائيه منخفضه نسبيا
لكن حراكهم له رمزيه كبيره في التقرير
التالي نتعرف على دوري واهميه جنود
الاحتياط في الجيش الاسرائيلي
تعد قوات الاحتياط في الجيش الاسرائيلي
العمود الفقري في اوقات الطوارئ التي تعيش
اسرائيل في ظلها معظم الوقت وينط بها
تنفيذ مختلف المهام الامنيه والعسكريه
يتكون الاحتياط من الجنود الذين ادوا
الخدمه العسكريه الاجباريه لمن يبلغون
السن القانونيه ويتم استدعائهم سنويا
لدورات تدريبيه وبعد الانتهاء من الخدمه
الالزاميه يتحول الجنود تلقائيا الى قوات
الاحتياط وهي تشكل اغلبيه تعداد القوات
المسلحه
يتمتع جنود الاحتياط بمهارات فائقه
يكتسبونها خلال خدمتهم الالزاميه
ويطورونها في فترات استدعائهم المختلفه
خصوصا اولئك الذين يخدمون في وحدات نوعيه
وحساسه مثل الوحدات الخاصه واجهزه
الاستخبارات وسلاح الجو وضعت اسس هيكليه
الجيش ضمن مبادئ نظريه الامن القومي مطلع
خمسينيات القرن الماضي في عهد مؤسس الدوله
ديفيد بينغوريون ضمن تصور حاجه اسرائيل
لما سمي جيش المواطن
وترجم هذا الشعار بنظريه التجنيد الشامل
او الامه تحت السلاح وهو ما يسمح ببقاء كل
الاسرائيليين ضمن الخدمه الالزاميه ومن ثم
الانتقال بعد ذلك الى الخدمه ضمن صفوف
قوات الاحتياط حتى عمر متقدم
وينتظم الجيش الاسرائيلي ضمن مجموعه من
المستويات الجيش النظامي ويعمل على مدار
العام قوات الاحتياط القوات المحترفه او
الخاصه وتعنى بتنفيذ المهام الحساسه
والمعقده سواء داخل الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله او خارجها لا تزال نسبه رفض
التجنيد الطوعي منخفضه جدا في الجيش
الاسرائيلي على خلفيه رفض التغييرات
القضائيه لكن لحراكها رمزيه كبرى بضع مئات
من الطيارين في سلاح الجو القوه الضاربه
في الجيش الاسرائيلي وافراد ضمن الخدمات
الفنيه واللوجستيه وبضع عشرات من وحده
لوتر المختصه في تاهيل الجنود على ما يسمى
مكافحه الارهاب والقمص لكن الخشيه هي من
انعكاس هذه التطورات غير المسبوقه في
تاريخ اسرائيل على تماسك الجيش وكفاءته
وعلى مصير ما يسميه قاده اسرائيل جيش
المواطن
[موسيقى]
لا يوجد هجوم اوكراني مضاد يقول رئيس
بيلاروسيا اليكساندر لوكاشينكو يوجد لكنه
فشل يرد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
وذلك خلال استضافه لنظيره وحليفه المقرب
واشنطن على الخط ومن هناك قال وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي ان اوكرانيا استعادت
نحو خمسين في المئه من الاراضي التي سيطرت
عليها روسيا مضيفا ان الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد سيستمر عده اشهر وعلى الارض تصدر
تصدر المشهد هجوم روسي على ميناء اوديسا
جنوبيه اوكرانيا
في التفاصيل وخلال اول لقاء بينهما منذ
تصعيد قوات فاجنر في يونيو حزيران الماضي
بحث الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين مع
نظيره البيلاروسيه
تداعياته وجود هذه القوات في بلاده واكد
الرئيس البيلاروسي ان بلاده تسيطر على
قوات فاجنر وتمنعها من التوجه الى بولندا
مشيرا الى ان خسائر القوات الاوكرانيه منذ
الرابع من يوليو تموز الجاري بلغت 26 الف
عسكري وحذر لوكاشينكو من نيه النيتو ضم
الجزء الغربي من اوكرانيا الى بولندا حسب
تصريحه
بدات تقلقنا فهم يريدون الذهاب الى الغرب
ويطلبون الاذن بذلك سالتهم لاي غرض قالوا
انهم يريدون الذهاب في رحله الى وارسو
جيشوف بالنسبه لهم امر حساس فعندما حاربوا
في بخموت كانوا يعلمون من اين تصلوا
الاليات العسكريه ولذلك فان هذه المنطقه
كارثه بالنسبه لهم بالطبع احاول السيطره
عليهم وابقائهم في مركز بيلاروسيا لا اريد
اعاده نشرهم هناك لانهم مستاءون ولابد من
الاشاده بهم فهم يدركون جيدا ما يحدث حول
دوله الاتحاد
وشدد الرئيس البيلاروسي اليكساندر
لوكيشنكو على ان تجزئه اوكرانيا وضم
مناطقها الغربيه الى الاراضي البولنديه
امر غير مقبول بالنسبه لبيلاروسيا
هناك احاديث كثيره في الاونه الاخيره بشان
ضم اوكرانيا الى النيتو على مراحل وتحت
هذا الشعار يريدون الاستيلاء على غرب
اوكرانيا وضمها الى بولندا هذا هو ثمن
المشاركه النشطه للبولنديين في النزاع ضد
القوات الروسيه اما بالنسبه لنا فان قطع
الجزء الغربي من اوكرانيا وتجزئتها وتسليم
بولندا اراضي اوكرانيه يعد امرا غير مقبول
اطلب منكم النظر في هذه القضيه ودعمنا
واذا دعمتمونا وطلب سكان غرب اوكرانيا من
المساعده بالطبع سنقدم لهم الدعم
والمساعده بكل الطرق المتاحه
من جانب قال الرئيس الروسي ان الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد فشل
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد فشل لم ندمر من
قبل هذا العدد من الاليات العسكريه
الاجنبيه خلال يوم واحد فمن الجانب الاخر
كانت الوحدات مجهزه بالكامل بالمعدات
الاجنبيه
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتوني
بلينكن ان اوكرانيا استعادت نحو 50% من
الاراضي التي احتلتها روسيا في بدايه
هجومها على حد تعبيره اضاف في حديث للشبكه
سي ان ان انه واثق من نصر الاوكرانيين وان
نتائج الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد ستظهر
خلال اشهر
لقد استعاد الاوكرانيون بالفعل نحو خمسين
بالمئه من الاراضي التي احتلتها روسيا في
بدايه هجومها وهم الان ياخذون معركه صعبه
لاستعاده المزيد ولا نزال في الايام
المبكره نسبيا من هجومهم المضاد وهم
يخوضون معركه قاسيه حيث اقام الروز دفاعات
قويه لكنني مقتنع ان المعدات والدعم الذي
تلقته اوكرانيا لم يتم الزج به بالكامل
بعد في هذه المعركه وهم على عكس الروس
يقاتلون من اجل ارضهم ومستقبلهم وحريتهم
وهذا هو العنصر الحاسم واعتقد ان ذلك
سيتضح خلال عده اشهر
فالتطورات الميدانيه قال المتحدث باسم
قياده عمليات الجنوب في الجيش الاوكراني
ان شخصين قتل واصيب اكثر من عشرين في قصف
روسيا استهدف مدينه اوديسا خلال الساعه
الماضيه اضاف ان القوات الروسيه استخدمت
خمسه انواع على الاقل من الصواريخ بينها
صواريخ او نيكس واسكندر وان اضرارا ماديه
لحقت بميناء المدينه ومناطق سكنيه نتيجه
القصف الروسي
وكانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قد قالت ان
قواتها شنت الليله الماضيه غاره على منشات
في اوديسا يجري فيها التحضير لاعمال
وصفتها بالارهابيه وبينما قالت الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه ان القصف الروسي استهدف
كاتدرائيه التجلي في اوديسا رجحت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان تدمير الكاتدرائيه كان
بسبب صاروخ اوكراني وقد وصف وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني متروكوليبا الهجوم على اوديسا
بانه الاكبر على ميناء حيوي للامن الغذائي
العالمي وحث الوزير الاوكراني جميع الدول
والمنظمات على ادانه ما وصفها بجريمه
الحرب الوحشيه الروسيه على اوديسا من جهه
توعد الرئيس الاوكراني
بالرد على الهجوم واصفا اياه بالارهابي
ينظم الينا حول هذا الموضوع من موسكو
رولاند بيتجاموف المحلل السياسي
والاستراتيجي وينضم الينا من باكو مواريدو
جاري المحلل محلل شؤون الدفاع السابق في
حلف الناتو مرحبا بكما سنبدا معك رولاند
بيجاموف على اي اساس يعتبر الرئيس الروسي
ان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد قد فشل
مساء الخير تحياتي لكم والديكم الكريم
ولساده المشاهدين طبعا بوتين اعلنا ذلك
قبل اسبوع واحد يعني حول هذا الهجوم
وبالفعل يعتبر ان الهجوم الاوكراني فاشل
يعني كنا ننتظر هذا الهجوم منذ زمنا بعيد
في الحرفه الماضيه ثم في الشتاء بعد ذلك
في الربيع واخيرا بدا الهجوم في اربعه من
الشهر حزيران يونيو الماضي وحتى الان لا
توجد هناك اي نتائج ملموسه من هذا الهجوم
وهذا ليس راي فقط اما راي معظم الخبراء
العسكريين في العالم
والمؤسسات العسكريه المحترمه
بما في ذلك المعهد الاستراتيجيه الغربيه
وهذا الهجوم بالف حتى الان روسيا نجحت في
هذا الدفاع الناش الاوكرانيون لا يستطيعون
خرق الضفاد الروسيه هي محاصنه جيدا بل في
بعض المناطق في شمال الروسي ينتقلون الى
الحجوم المضاد خاصه في المحور كوبي في
شمال الجبهه ومع ذلك يقول الوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انه متفائل بان هذا الهجوم
المضاد سيحقق النتائج
المرجوه منه وهنا سؤال مريدزيو جاري على
اي اساس يبدو وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
متفائلا الى هذا الحد رغم ان المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين انفسهم غير راضين حتى الان
وفق تصريحاتهم عما تحقق في هذا الهجوم
المضاد
في الحقيقه
لا تزال الحرب مستمره والهجوم الاوكرانيه
المضاد ايضا سيستمر لفتره لدينا اذا
مجموعه فاغنر التي انتقلت الى بيلاروسيا
وتحاول ان تهدد اوكرانيا من الشمال اذن
بوتين يتحالف الان مع دوله اخرى وهي
بيلاروسيا
وهي دميته وهو يحاول
من خلال فتح جبهه اخرى
هل هذا هو المقصود سيد رولاند من وراء
التصريحات التي ادلى بها لوكاشينكو اليوم
وقال فيها ان قوات فاجنر تريد التوجه نحو
بولندا وانه يمنعها حتى الان هل هذه هي
الرساله
ما اعتقد انه هذه هي كانت الرساله لرغم
اننا كان يتحدث بنبره مزحه هذه المره وهذا
اسلوبه ويبدو هذه كانت رساله التخدير
لحلف الناتو وللغرب الى انقاذ مجلس
حجر فرناطه واوكرانيا في السادس وعشرين
يوليو يعني قبل
تم ارسال هذه الرسائل ولكن هذا يعني من
ناحيه اخرى
احاول ان
اسيطر على هذه المجموعه في وسط البلاد
ولكن في كل حال من الاحوال هذا عباره ان
الرد الروسي البيلاروسيا المشتركه
ليست الدميه كما قال ضيفكم ولكن هي دوله
هنا التي اخدمك دوله الاتحاد بين روسيا
وبيلاروسيا تشكلت منذ اكثر من عاما فلذلك
الامر يختلف ان العلاقات بين روسيا ودول
اخرى فلذلك روسيا قالت لها في حال اي هجوم
اوكراني او او بولندي على بيلاروس روسيا
ستتدخل بوتين قال ذلك قبل ايام يعني كان
هناك
الحديثات
ما الرساله التي يراد ايصالها من وراء
حديث لوكاشينكو عن امكانيه التوجه فاغنر
الى بولندا ولمن هي موجهه اصلا
الرساله هناك هناك تحرك القوات البولنديه
اداتها حوالي 26 ونصف الان تمركزت بالقرب
من الخطوط البيلاروسيه مثلا التمركز الاول
على مسافه 50 كيلومتر ميدان مدينه
البيلاروسيا عاصمه مقاطعه بريس
والتجمع الاخر هو
على مسافه 100 كلم
عن مدينه غرودنا التي ايضا عاصمه
المقاطعه الاوكرانيه التي كانت قبلها
الحرب العالميه الثانيه بولندا سيطرت
عليها بعض الحرب الاهليه في روسيا وانفكاك
الامبراطوريه الروسيه
وبولندا الان كما تعرفون هناك في بولندا
حزبه القومي متطرف رخيصه
له طموخ في السيطره من جديد الاراضي غرب
اوكرانيا وغرب بيلاروسيا وخاصه كل هذا
الحديث في بولندا وخطابات ناريه تعطي
قبيله الانتخابات في بولندا في اكتوبر
المقبل ولذلك
يوجه رساله رساله التغذير
الجيران هي بولندا
هذه الرسائل الوارده على لساني لوكاشينكو
كيف يمكن ان تتعامل معها بولندا من وجهه
نظرك وايضا النيتو
نعم سيد مورد السؤال لك امين
كان هناك تصريح ساخيف سمعنا ديكتاتور
البيلاروسي يحمل ورقه ويقرا ما طلبه منه
بوتين
ولكن هذا الديكتاتور كان يستخدم اللاجئين
كالسلاح من اجل ان يهدد الاستقرار
الاوروبي والان
يقول الشخص الخير سيدو بغض النظر عن كل
ذلك انا اسالك عن كيفيه تعامل الناتو مع
هذه الرسائل ماذا سيفعل اذا ما ورد على
لسان الرئيس البيلاروسي
للاسف يبدو ان الاتصال انقطع مع السيد
موريزيو جاري
محلل شؤون الدفاع السابق في حلف الناتو
كان ضيفنا من باكو نشكره ونشكر ايضا ضيفنا
من موسكو السيد رولاند
السياسي والمحلل
المحلل السياسي والاستراتيجي من موسكو اذا
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
الى السودان مئه يوم من القتال بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع جهود الوساطه
الاقليميه والدوليه تراوح مكانها دون
اختراق يثمر تثبيتا لوقف لاطلاق النار
قتال تسبب في تشريد ما يزيد على ثلاثه
ملايين سوداني منهم اكثر من 700 الف فروا
الى دول مجاوره فكيف يبدو المشهد على
الارض افاد مراسل الجزيره في السودان
بتصاعد دخان كثيف من حي كافوري شرقي مدينه
الخرطوم بحري بتزامن مع تحليق مستمر
لطائرات الحربيه وقال مراسلنا ان الطائرات
الحربيه التابعه للجيش حلقت اليوم بكثافه
شرقيه الخرطوم وقصفت اهدافا للدعم السريع
بمنطقه حله حمد في الخرطوم بحري تزامن ذلك
مع اطلاق قوات الدعم السريع المضادات
الارضيه وكان مراسلنا قد افاد بوقوع
اشتباكات متقطعه بين الجيش والدعم السريع
وسط مدينه ام درمان بينما قال مصدر الجيش
الجزيره ان مسيرات للدعم السريع هاجمت
اهدافا للجيش في حي الوادي واوقعت عددا من
الجرحى
ونشرت قوات العمل الخاص التابعه للجيش
السوداني اليوم مقاطع مصوره قالت انها
لعمليات تمشيط واسعه تقوم بها في شارع
النيل ومحيط القياده العامه بالعاصمه
الخرطوم وتظهر المشاهد مجموعه من القوات
المسلحه السودانيه في المنطقه التي قالت
انها تسيطر عليها
قالت مصادر للجزيره ان عدد القتلى جراء
تبادل القصف المدفعي بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع في نيالا عاصمه ولايه
جنوب دارفور ارتفع الى اكثر من 20 وافادت
المصادر بان المدينه تعاني من شلل في
مظاهر الحياه وتزايد حركه نزوح المواطنين
خارج المدينه بسبب استمرار الاشتباكات
لليوم الرابع وتدهور الوضع المعيشي وشح
السلع الغذائيه اضافت المصادر ان الوضع
الصحي يتفاقم بسبب تعطل اغلب المستشفيات
انتقد عضو مجلس السياده السوداني ياسر
العطا سياسات الرئيس الكيني ويليام روتو
تجاه السودان وقال العطا في تصريحات خلال
زيارته لقوات العمل الخاص في منطقه سلاح
المهندسين بالخرطوم ان كينيا تدعم من
سماهم المرتزقه في السودان
زي الرئيس الكيني يجي زي الرئيس الكيني
يقول انا اجيب قوات شرقي افريقيا يا
الرئيس الكيني يا رئيس الكيني
والشر افريقية خليها في محلها انت جيب انت
جيبك جيش الكيني تعال والله والله غصب
واحد فيهم بيرجع تاني ما في ما في
[موسيقى]
الى اسبانيا حيث اغلقت صناديق الاقتراع في
الانتخابات العامه المبكره وظهرت النتائج
الاوليه بعد فرز اكثر من 80% من الاصوات
ان الحزب الشعبي المحافظ زعيم المعارضه
البرلمانيه يحتل حاليا المركز الاول بين
اكبر احزاب البرلمان المقبل برصيد 132
مقعدا وهو ما يمثل صعودا كبيرا مقارنه
بتسعه وثمانين مقعدا كانت لديه في
البرلمان المنحل وياتي في المركز الثاني
الحزب الاشتراكي الحاكم برصيد 125 مقعدا
محققا تقدما عن رصيده في البرلمان السابق
المتمثل في مئه وعشرين مقعدا
معنا من امام مقر الحزب الشعبي في مدريد
مراسل الجزيره ايمن الزبير ايمن نقترب معك
اكثر من المشهد ومعنى هذه النتائج الاوليه
حتى الان
سي تستمر عمليه الفرز ومع تقدمها ارتفعت
شيئا ما مقاعد الحزب الشعبي المعارض الذي
يتصدر الى حدود هذه الساعه الانتخابات لكن
حتى وان تحالف بهذه النتائج مع حزب اقصى
اليمين ما زال بعيدا عن الاغلبيه المطلقه
176 مقعد هو ما يحتاجه هذا الحلف لتشكيل
حكومه هنا يمكن الحديث في الدقائق الاخيره
عن ارتفاع معنويات انصار هذا الحزب لكن
داخل مقر الحزب الشعبي الاصداء القادمه من
هناك تقول ان هناك اجواء جنائزيه بعد
الانتصار الواسع الذي حققته او حققه هذا
الحزب في الانتخابات البلديه كان هناك
رهان كبير على تحقيق الفوز في هذه
الانتخابات لكن ذلك الى حدود الساعه لم
يتحقق حاليا يتم فرز اصوات مدينه مدريد
المعروفه
بتاييدها لليمين لكن المهمه الى حدود
الساعات تبدو شبه مستحيله وبالتالي تحققت
التوقعات استطلاعات الراي التي اجراها
التلفزيون الرسمي الاسباني الذي تحدث ربما
عن تقارب في الفرص وعن امكانيه اعاده
تشكيل حكومه يساريه صحيح ان الحزب
الاشتراكي يحتل المرتبه الثانيه لكن
بامكانه التحالف مع باقي الاحزاب اليساريه
وربما مع الاحزاب القوميه وان كانت مهمه
عصيه مهمه شبه مستحيله لذلك بعض المصادر
داخل الحزب الاشتراكي تحدثت لنا عن حاله
جمود وتحدثت عن سيناريوهين اثنين
يتحدث عن اعاده الانتخابات او سيناريو اخر
ينجح فيه الحزب الاشتراكي في اقناع باقي
الاحزاب بتشكيل الحكومه كل هذا الكلام في
انتظار النتائج النهائيه الان تم فرس
86.4 من الاصوات تفصلنا دقائق قليله عن
معرفه النتائج النهائيه شاهدوا الان هناك
حاله فرح في اوساط انصار هذا الحزب لان
التحالف اليميني الى حدود الساعه جمع ما
يناهز
مقعد بالنسبه للحزبه الشعبي وثلا 33
بالنسبه لحزب فوكس اي يقترب من الاغلبيه
المطلقه لذلك علينا ان ننتظر فرز اخر
الاصوات الوضع وكاننا امام مباراه من كره
القدم لكن العاده في مثل هذا التوقيت تكون
هناك احتفالات صاخبه في شارع خينوفا مقر
الحزب الشعبي الاسباني شكرا لك ايمن
الزبير مراسلنا من امام مقر الحزب الشعبي
في مدريد بطبيعه الحال تبقى معنا ونتابع
معك اولا باول صدور النتائج النهائيه شكرا
لك ايمن
[موسيقى]
اطلاقوا عمليه روما للتصدي للاسباب
الاساسيه للهجره غير النظاميه هو العنوان
الابرز لمؤتمر استضافته ايطاليا لمناقشه
الهجره عبر المتوسط بحضور قاده من المنطقه
والاتحاد الاوروبي والمؤسسات الماليه
الدوليه ثمه تعهد من المشاركين في مؤتمر
روما باتاحه التمويل لتطوير دول المهاجرين
ودول العبور رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه تقول
انه سينظم قريبا مؤتمر للمانحين في اعقاب
مؤتمر الهجره وفي مقابل التعهدات هناك
انتقادات اوروبا لم تتعلم شيئا من تواطؤها
في الانتهاكات الفظيعه المرتكبه ضد
المهاجرين في ليبيا هذا ما قالته منظمه
هيومن رايتس واتش
نحو حياه كريمه او هكذا يحسبون لا يعدم
طلاب الهجره شمالا وسائل لبلوغ غايتهم في
النصف الاول من هذا العام بحسب التقديرات
الامميه وصل اكثر من 100 الف مهاجر سري
الى اوروبا قادمين عن طريق البحر من سواحل
شمال افريقيا وتركيا ولبنان
ومع ارتفاع وتيره الهجره غير النظاميه
يتنامى القلق في الضفه المستقبله هذا
مؤتمر في ايطاليا يناقش المساله دعيت اليه
دول المتوسطيه واخرى من الشرق الاوسط الى
جانب الاتحاد الاوروبي والمؤسسات الماليه
الدوليه
يسعى اللقاء لتعزيز جهود مكافحه الهجره
غير النظاميه والاتجار بالبشر
يعرفوا الامر المهم من كل ذلك هو تقديم
المساعده الانسانيه والتعاون لتطوير مستوى
العيش في افريقيا وبالتحديد من دول انطلاق
الهجرات وفيما يخص التصدي للهجره غير
النظاميه علينا ان نعزز التعاون الامنيه
مع السلطات القضائيه في مختلف الدول ونشدد
التشريعات لردع المهربين ومنعهم من
الانتقال من مكان الى اخر
تدرك ميلوني التي تقود جهودا متعثره لوقف
تدفق المهاجرين الى بلادها ان اي عمل
سيبقى ناقصا بدون ما تعرف ببلدان المغادره
المراد اذا تعزيز التنميه هناك لتقليل
دوافع الهجره ولم لا ابرام اتفاق شراكه
النموذجي على غرار ذاك الموقع بين الاتحاد
الاوروبي وتونس للحد من وصول المهاجرين من
افريقيا الى اوروبا علينا جميعا مواجهه
الهجره غير النظاميه ولا يمكننا ان نكون
ممرا لاشخاص مجرمين يرتكبون الفظائع بحق
المهاجرين وخفروا السواحل التونسي سيقوم
بواجبه لحمايه البلاد بخلاف ما يعتقد
الكثيرون فان المهربين غير مرحب بهم في
تونس
ليسوا كذلك ايضا في ليبيا بلد العبور
الباحث عن شراكه حقيقيه مع الاوروبيين
لمعالجه ملف الهجره لا نقبل توطين في
ليبيا اي مهاجر نريد معاملته معامله حسنه
نريد الوقوف عليهم وضحاهم الانسان الوضع
الانساني هو اول درجه من درجات الاهتمام
بالنسبه لبلدي ومن تم عمليه التنميه في
مواطنهم الاصليه التي يغادرون وناكد ان
ليبيا بلد عبور وليست بلد مصدر لهذه
الهجره وجود قناه الحوار بين اوروبا ودول
المغادره بدا امرا ايجابيا في نظر كثيرين
لكنك ستجد ما يقلقهم ان دول الجنوب باتت
مثل الاوروبيين تعتبر الهجره مشكله
والمشكله ان دول الضفه الشماليه لا تفتح
تطالبها بتعاون اكبر يدرء عنها ما تراه
خطر الهجره والمهاجرين
[موسيقى]
ونبقى في موضوع ازمه المهاجرين التي تنعقد
بشانها قمه في ايطاليا حيث نسلط الضوء على
البحر الابيض المتوسط كواحد من ابرز طرق
المهاجرين واخطرها تعتبر تونس نقطه انطلاق
رئيسيه للمهاجرين الذين يحاولون الوصول
الى اوروبا عبر المتوسط انطلاقا من مدينتي
صفاقس وجرجيس جنوبا كما تعد ليبيا نقطه
انطلاقا رئيسيه ايضا لقوارب المهاجرين
المتهالكه والمكتظه غالبا من مدينه زواره
الساحليه غرب البلاد ومن تبرق شرقا على
نحو الاقل لكن قبل تونس وليبيا بلدي
العبور يبدا حلم الوصول الى اوروبا من دول
افريقيا جنوب الصحراء في رحله محفوفه
بالمخاطر عبر مسافات طويله يتهددهم فيها
العطش وعصابات التهريب وقطاع الطرق كما
شكلت بعض بلدان الشرق الاوسط مثل سوريا
ومصر ولبنان مصدرا للمهاجرين نحو اوروبا
عبر تونس او ليبيا وقبل ان يواصل
المهاجرون الرحله نحو بلدان اوروبيه اخرى
تكون ايطاليا هي الوجهه الاولى لمعظمهم لا
سيما منطقه لامبيدوز التي لا يفصلها عن
مدينه صفاقس التونسيه سوى 190 كيلومترا
البحر المتوسط ظل منذ سنوات يتصدر
المسارات الاكثر فتكا بالمهاجرين رغم
النداءات الانسانيه وجهود منظمات الانقاذ
الاوروبيه وفق المنظمه الدوليه للهجره فان
الربع الاول من العام الحالي سجل مصرع
اكثر من 400 واربعين مهاجرا في مياه
المتوسط وهي اعلى حصيله لنفس الفتره منذ
عام 2017 لا يتضمن ذلك الاحصاء مئات من
ضحايا كارثه غرق مركب المهاجرين
السواحل اليونان منتصف يونيو الماضي في
احدى اسوا الماسي في المتوسط خلال عقد من
الزمن ومنذ عام 2014 احصت المنظمه الدوليه
للهجره وفاه اكثر من 20 الف مهاجر غرقا في
مياه البحر المتوسط وسط شكوكا بان اجهزه
خفر السواحل الاوروبيه تتقاعس عن انقاذ
المهاجرين من مدينه فلورنسا في ايطاليا
ينضم الينا السيد لويجي اشيلي الاستاذ في
مركز سياسه الهجره بمعهد الجامعه
الاوروبيه في فلورنسا مرحبا بك
كيف وجدت هذه العناوين التي يطرحها
المؤتمر المنعقد في ايطاليا في امكانيه ان
تعالج هذه المساله مساله الهجره غير
الشرعيه
ان هذا المؤتمر ما هو سوى مؤتمر اخر وليس
خطوه
نحو وجهه جديده نتحدث عن نفس الوجهه رمي
المسؤوليه على دول اخرى هذا المؤتمر ياتي
اسبوعا بعد توقيع الاتحاد الاوروبي اتفاق
شراكه مع تونس
حيث تعهد تقريبا بمليار يورو لم اكن مخطئا
من اجل التصدي لتهريب المهاجرين هذا امر
لا يبدو لي منطقيا لان نسير في نفس المسار
ولا اعتقد انه سوف يحقق الكثير من
النجاحات لا اعتقد ان هناك حلول
مستدامه لهذه الكارثه الحاليه التي نشهدها
ولكن كان هناك حديث عن ضروره الاستثمار في
تنميه الدول التي يخرج منها هؤلاء
المهاجرون
ومحاوله مساعدتها وتحسين ظروف هؤلاء لماذا
لا تبدو متفائلا بامكانيه فعلا تحقيق ذلك
لانه اولا
بالنسبه الى المدى المتوسط والقصير انا لا
ارى اي فرصه في تحسين الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه في تلك البلدان اذا نحن نتحدث
عن هدف بعيد الامان هذا في افضل
السيناريوهات على المستويين القصير
والمتوسط الهدف
لن يتحقق الظروف الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
سوف لن تتحسن هي فقط محاوله لذر الرماد في
العيون لاحتواء الازمه لابقاء المهاجرين
خارج اوروبا لا اكثر ولا اقل انا لا اعتقد
فعلا انه هناك نوايا حقيقيه ضمن هذه
الشركات من اجل تحسين معيشه المواطنين في
تلك البلدان ووقف المهاجرين التدفق اعتقد
ان دخول في صفقات في تلك الدول هدفها
ابقاء المهاجرين خارجه اراضي ولكن ولكن
سيد الويدجي الى اي مدى يمكن ان تكون دول
دول العبور والتي تعاني كذلك من هذه
الظاهره دول مثل تونس مثل ليبيا مثل مصر
الى اي مدى يمكن ان تكون عاملا ضاغطا على
دول الشمال في اوروبا من اجل الذهاب نحو
فعليا معالجه الاسباب اسباب هذه الاجراء
في دولا دول المنشا
الى اي مدى الى اي مدى يمكن ان تكون هذه
الدول دول العبور
ان تشكل ضغطا على الدول الاوروبيه من اجل
ان تساعد في تحسين ظروف دول التي يخرج
منها المهاجرون غير الشرعيون
الى ربع المسؤوليه على عناصر خارجيه من
خلال هذا الاتفاقات مع ليبيا وتونس
ربما تسالين عن ظروف نجاح هذه الاتفاقيات
دعنا ننتقل الى سؤال اخر سيد لويجي ربما
لا يصلك المعنى كما يجب ماذا عن ضروره
التصدي لشبكات التهريب
وجرى الحديث يعني بشكل مكثف عن هذا
الموضوع هل الشراكه بين كل هذه الدول
المتواجده حاليا في هذا المؤتمر يمكن
فعليا ان تجد حلا لشبكات التهريب
يعني
سؤال وجيه لان شعار الذي يتكرر دائما هو
لنوقف هذا القوارب
لنتصدى لهذا النموذج نموذج العمل
بتهريب المهاجرين من اجل انقاذ المهاجرين
وما شاهدناه في السنوات الاخيره هو ان
التصدي او طريقه التصدي لشبكات التهريب هي
التي تؤدي الى ولاده المزيد من هذه
الشبكات في العلوم الاجتماعيه نتحدث هنا
عن نبوءه تتحقق
بحد ذاتها
من خلال تنفيذ اجراءات الاحتواء هذه من
خلال منع المهاجرين من وصولي الى بلداننا
نحن نفاقم المشكله لاننا نزيد العرض على
شبكات
وطلب على شبكات التهريب
اشكرك اذا السيد
لويجي
الاستاذ في مركز سياسه الهجره بمعهد
الجامعه الاوروبيه في فلورنسا ضيفنا من
فرنسا في ايطاليا شكرا
[موسيقى]
شاب تونسي يضرب النار في نفسه في وسط
العاصمه التونسيه ما تسبب له في حروق من
الدرجه الثانيه لم تعرف بعد اسباب اقدام
الشاب البالغ من العمر 35 عاما على هذا
الفعل وان كانت احصاءات نشرتها منظمه
المنتدى التونسي للحقوق الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه تشير الى انه منذ مطلع العام
الجاري والى حدود شهر مايو اقدم 72 شخصا
على الانتحار في تونس وتقول المنظمه في
تقاريرها ان اهم الدوافع للانتحار هي
الامراض العقليه والنفسيه والاحتجاج على
الاوضاع الاجتماعيه الصعبه بطبيعه الحال
محاولات الانتحار على خلفيه ظروف اجتماعيه
واقتصاديه ليست حكرا على تونس لكن مثل هذه
الاحداث تذكرنا بصعوبات الحياه التي تدفع
البعض في لحظه ياس واحباط الى التخلص من
الحياه ذاتها والامل كل الامل ان تتحسن
اوضاع الجميع وتنتشر ثقافه الاهتمام
بالصحه النفسيه للتعامل مع الازمات بهذا
مشاهدينا نصل الى ختام حصاد هذه الليله
شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]